WITHOUT BIAS.
WE HAVE THAT AND SO MUCH MORE
IN BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT, MORE
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE THAT
THE DEEP STATE ACTORS ARE
DOING EVERYTHING WITHIN THEIR
POWER TO DAMAGE, UNSEAT DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHAT IS WORSE THAT THAT THE
ON AND USING THIS LEAK TO
BLUDGEON THE PRESIDENT
POLITICALLY.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, MEMBERS OF
THE DEEP STATE RAN TO THE
FAVORITE LIBERAL MEDIA OUTLET
THE "WASHINGTON POST" WITH THE
LATEST TARGETED LEAK MEANT TO
SMEAR THE PRESIDENT.
HERE THE HEADLINE --
TRUMP, NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISERS WARNED HIM NOT TO
CONGRATULATE VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND HE DID IT ANYWAY."
BUT IT CONTAINS FAKE NEWS.
SHOCKING.
FOX NEWS REPORTING SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL SAYING
IT'S LIKELY THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP NEVER SAW THE MEMO THAT
CONTAINED THE WARNING ABOUT
PUTIN BECAUSE HE WAS BRIEFED
ABOUT HIS CONVERSATION WITH
THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT OVER THE
PHONE.
BUT JUST LIKE ALWAYS GETTING
THE FACTS RIGHT DOESN'T MATTER
TO THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA.
THEY FAMED UP THE PHONY
FEIGNED OUTRAGE MACHINE.
LET'S LOOK.
>> IT'S NOT JUST WHAT HE SAID.
IT'S ALWAYS WHAT HE DID NOT
SAY THAT HAS COME IN HIS PARTY
ANGRY THIS MORNING.
>> IT WOULD BE LIKE J. EDGAR
HOOVER AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
F.B.I. CALLING OUT CAPONE TO
CONGRATULATE HIM ON BANK
ROBBERY.
>> IS IT GO TOO FAR TO SAY
WHITE HOUSE FAILING AMERICA ON
WORLD STAGE?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT OUT OF
HIS WAY TO PRAISE PUTIN AND
NOT BRING UP EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT AND CONTROVERSIAL
TOPICS.
>> IT'S THE LATEST OF WHAT IS
A LONG PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR BY
THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT OFTEN
CONGRATULATES LEADERS WHO ARE
NOT DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED AND
OFTEN GIVES AUTOCRATIC
DICTATORS CONGRATULATIONS.
>> HE IS NOT THE FIRST.
WE WILL SEE IF HE CHANGES HIS
COURSE.
>> ANOTHER DEEP STATE ACTOR
JOHN BRENNAN CONTINUING HIS
BASELESS ATTACKS ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW BRENNAN
FLOATS THIS CONSPIRACY THEORY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK HE IS AFRAID OF THE
PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA.
>> WHY?
>> ONE COULD SPECULATE TO WHY.
THAT THE RUSSIANS MAY HAVE
SOMETHING ON HIM PERSONALLY.
THEY COULD ROLL OUT AND MAKE
HIS LIFE MORE DIFFICULT.
CLEARLY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO IMPROVE
RELATIONS WITH RUSSIA BUT THE
FACT THAT HE HAS HAD A FAWNING
ATTITUDE TOWARD MR. PUTIN HAS
NOT SAID ANYTHING NEGATIVE
ABOUT HIM.
HE CONTINUES TO SAY TO ME HE
DOES HAVE SOMETHING TO FEAR.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
ISN'T JOHN BRENNAN THE GUY --
LET'S SEE.
HE VOTED FOR A COMMUNIST FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BACK IN THE '70s.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
NONPARTISAN.
BY THE WAY, HOW DID HE BECOME
THE CYBERDIRECTOR?
NOW IN REALITY HE IS NOTHING
MORE THAN AN OBAMA DEEP STATE
STOOGE.
HE RECENTLY TWEETED OUT A
THREAT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP --
>> Sean: ANDY McCABE GOT
FIRED BECAUSE THE F.B.I.
RECOMMENDED HE BE FIRED.
THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT RECOMMENDED THE SAME.
IT WASN'T DONALD TRUMP.
THAT IS THE TYPE OF COMMENT
THAT NOW SHOWS WHY A WHOPPING
74% OF YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE NOW SAYING THAT YOU THINK
THIS GROUP OF UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS, DEEP STATE
OPERATIVES ARE SECRETLY TRYING
TO MANIPULATE POLICY AND
OPINION.
IT'S MORE PARENT THAN EVER
THAT PEOPLE LIKE BRENNAN,
CLAPPER AND THE REST OF THEM,
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO HIDE
THE ABUSE AND THE BIAS AGAINST
TRUMP.
THEY WANT HIM OUT OF OFFICE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HE DOES OR
DOESN'T DO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LIKE HE ALWAYS
DOES IS FIGHTING BACK AND HE
TWEETED OUT --
>> Sean: THE MEDIA'S NUMBER
ONE OBJECTIVE IS TAKE DOWN THE
PRESIDENT.
WE POINT THAT OUT EVERY NIGHT.
WE KNOW THE DEEP STATE KNOWS
THIS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO EXPLOIT
THIS AND TRYING TO
INDOCTRINATE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THERE WERE 125 DEEP STATE
LEAKS IN 126 DAYS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THE GOAL IS OBVIOUS.
THE MEDIA WON'T TELL YOU THAT.
LIKE THEY WON'T TELL YOU IN
2012 INTERESTING, PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA DID THE SAME
THING CONGRATULATING PUTIN
THAT THE MEDIA IS EXCORIATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
THAT IS HOW HYPOCRITICAL, THE
MEDIA, THE LEFT WING IN THE
COUNTRY ARE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE PRESS
RELEASE.
I READS IN PART --
>> Sean: THAT IS THE SAME
THING THAT TRUMP DID.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE OR
THEPEDIA CONDEMNATION?
THIS IS ONE BIG MASSIVE
HYPOCRITICAL DOUBLE STANDARD
ON DISPLAY.
SADLY WE SEE IT EVERY DAY.
THE MEDIA IS WHIPPING ITSELF
INTO A FRENZY ACTING LIKE THIS
IS A MAJOR NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
IT'S NOT.
BY THE WAY SINCE THE MEDIA
WON'T TELL YOU ABOUT THE FACTS
AS IT RELATES TO PRESIDENT
OBAMA ON RUSSIA WE WILL GIVE
THEM TO YOU.
THE RUSSIAN RESET AND THERE
SHE IS PRESENTING IT TO THE
COUNTERPART.
A PHOTO TOP AND A BAD ONE AT
THAT AND IT ACCOMPLISHED
NOTHING.
THEN YOU HAD OBAMA ON THE HOT
MIC WHISPERING TO DMITRY
MEDVEDEV.
"TELL VLADIMIR I WILL HAVE
MORE FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
MORE FLEXIBILITY AFTER."
WE'LL SHOW YOU THE TAPE.
>> TELL HIM AFTER THE ELECTION
I'LL HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY.
>> I TRANSMIT TO VLADIMIR.
>> Sean: HOW DID THAT WORK
OUT FOR OBAMA?
2014, CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES
OF THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
ISSUED EXPLICIT WARNING TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA, THE RUSSIANS
ARE COMING AND WANT TO
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS AND
PUTIN WANTS TO CREATE CHAOS IN
THE UNITED STATES AND AROUND
THE WORLD.
WHAT DID OBAMA DO?
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
INSTEAD KEEPING AN EYE ON
RUSSIA HE MOCKED CANDIDATE
TRUMP IN 2016 SAYING IT'S
RIDICULOUS THAT RUSSIA COULD
RIG AN ELECTION.
HE SAIDSTOP WHINING.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> THERE ARE NO SERIOUS PERSON
OUT THERE WHO WOULD SUGGEST
SOMEHOW YOU COULD EVEN RIG
AMERICA'S ELECTIONS.
IN PART BECAUSE THEY ARE SO DO
CENTRALIZED AND THE NUMBER OF
VOTES INVOLVED.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT IT
HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST.
OR THERE ARE INSTANCES THAT IT
WILL HAPPEN THIS TIME.
I ADVISE MR. TRUMP TO STOP
WHINING AND GO TRY TOIC MA HIS
CASE TO GET VOTES.
>> Sean: IT DOESN'T GET MORE
POMPOUS OR ARROGANT THAN THAT.
ACCORDING TO A NEW BOOK,
OBAMA'S OWN NATIONAL SECURITY
AID -- ADVISER SUSAN RICE
ISSUED A STANDDOWN ORDER
BECAUSE THEY WERE COMING UP
WITH OPTION TO COUNTER RUSSIA
ATTEMPT AT ELECTION
INTERPERIENCE?
-- INTERFERENCE?
THAT IS A SIMPLE TRUTH.
OBAMA WAS WARNED AND SAID IT
COULD NEVER HAPPEN.
STOP WHINING.
THE MEDIA WON'T REPORT THAT.
THEY WOULD RATHER ATTACK
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR SOMETHING
OBAMA HAD ALREADY DONE.
HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR 2016.
NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHO PAID FOR THE DOSSIER?
HILLARY.
YOU ARE BEING LIED TO.
THIS IS THE SAD PART.
ON A DAILY BASIS BY THE
DESTROYED TRUMP MEDIA AND
THOSE IN THE DEEP STATE.
THIS IS ON A SCALE AND LEVEL
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ AGREEING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL NEVER HAS BEEN
APPOINTED.
HE COULDN'T BE MORE RIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE PRESIDENT
IS 100% RIGHT.
THERE NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
APPOINTMENT OF SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THERE WAS NO PROBABLE CAUSE TO
BELIEVE CRIMES WERE COMMITTED.
I HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE TO
SUGGEST THAT THE CRIMES HAD
BEEN COMMITTED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
AS I SAID FROM DAY ONE THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A SPECIAL
INVESTIGATIVE COMMISSION,
NONPARTISAN APPOINTED BY
CONGRESS WITH SUBPOENA POWER
TO LOOK INTO THE ROLE OF
RUSSIA AND TRYING TO INFLUENCE
AMERICAN ELECTIONS AND TO TRY
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
PREVENTING IT IN THE FUTURE.
INSTEAD OF STARTING OUT WITH
FINGER POINTING AND TRYING TO
CRIMINALIZE POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS OF A GRAND JURY.
THAT HAS GOTTEN US NOWHERE.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
THE INVESTIGATION NEVER SHOULD
HAVE BEGUN.
>> Sean: WE WILL SPEAK TO
HIM IN A FEW MINUTES.
IN ADDITION TO THE COMMENTS,
THE FROM FES SOMEWHERE IS OUT
WITH A -- PROFESSOR IS OUT
WITH A NEW OP ED WHERE HE SAYS
IN THIS CASE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL HAS DONE MORE ARM THAN
GOOD.
IT'S POLITICIZED IT BEYOND
REPAIR AND HE ADS PUBLIC LOST
FAITH IN LEADERSHIP OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
F.B.I.
THEY DON'T TRUST CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEES AND
THEY DON'T KNOW WHO TO
BELIEVE.
AND THERE ARE LEAKS GALORE
FILED BY THE DENIALS OF LEAKS.
A TOTAL MESS.
WHAT DO WE SHOW FOR IT?
A HANDFUL OF LOW LEVEL INDICT
MENTS BASED LARGELY ON
ALLEGED CRIMES THAT ARE
TOTALLY UNRELATED OR ONLY
MARGINALLY RELATED TO THE
RUSSIAN ATTEMPT TO INFLUENCE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN 2016.
THE PROFESSOR IS 100% RIGHT.
MUELLER IS WAY BEYOND HIS
MANDATE.
THIS IS WHAT WE CALL
INVESTIGATIVE CREEP.
THE ENTIRE INVESTIGATION,
REMEMBER IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT TRUMP, RUSSIA,
COLLUSION.
IT DOESN'T EXIST AND NOW IT'S
A WITCH HUNT.
WHAT DOES THE PROFESSOR GET
FOR TELLING THE TRUTH ABOUT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THE
ANSWER IS TO BY ATTACKED BY
FAKE NEWS CNN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I SAW THE TWEET FROM THE
MORNING FROM THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ.
HE WILL PROBABLY ASK HIM TO
JOIN HUS LEGAL TEAM.
>> MAYBE HE HAS DECLINED.
>> IF HE COMES IN AT THE END
ON THE HIGH PROFILE SITUATION.
>> KNOWING THE PRESIDENT AND
DERSHOWITZ --
>> HE IS A CLOSER.
>> HE MAY BE JOINING THE LEGAL
TEAM AT SOME POINT.
WE'LL SOON FIND OUT.
>> Sean: COMMENTARY FROM A
GUY NAMED "WOLF."
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
OFFER DISSENTING OPINION THAT
GOES AGAINST DESTROY TRUMP
MEDIA TRUMP RUSSIA, COLLUSION,
CONSPIRACY THEORY AND NO
EVIDENCE AND IT HAS BEEN 14,
16 MONTHS.
BRAND NEW TONIGHT A GROUP OF
CONGRESSMAN, GATES, MEADOWS,
BIGS, THEY ARE DEMANDING THAT
THE REPORT THAT LED TO THE
DISGRACED FORMER F.B.I.
DIRECTOR, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE AND THE FIRING
BE MADE PUBLIC.
THE CONGRESSMEN WANT YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY WANT TO
BE TRANSPARENT.
THEY WANT YOU TO KNOW THE
SPECIFIC REASONS FOR WHY
McCABE WAS SHOWN THE DOOR
BECAUSE THEY ARE ARGUING
RIGHTLY SO THAT WHAT HE DID
COULD HAVE PUT THIS COUNTRY IN
DANGER.
YOU REMEMBER LATE FRIDAY NIGHT
McCABE WAS FIRED AT 9:59.
JUST BEFORE I WENT OFF THE
AIR.
WHY?
FOR LYING TO INVESTIGATORS AND
LEAKING TO THE MEDIA AND LYING
UNDER OATH.
EVEN THOUGH THE EVIDENCE IS
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR WHY McCABE
WAS FIRED BUT THE MEDIA TRIED
TO BLAME IT ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HE HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
THE F.B.I. DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY IS SHOOTING
DOWN THE LIBERAL MEDIA LIES.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HE IS
SAYING ABOUT McCABE'S
FIRING.
>> I WANT TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT I CAN SAY ABOUT THE
PROCESS BUT I WILL TELL YOU MY
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR PROCESS IS FOLLOWED, THAT
IT RELIES ON OBJECTIVE INPUT
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT'S NOT